hey guys this is dennis i found i think
here and i'm david griffin your resident
comic looking video game guru and this
is our review of the final final not the
season finale but the series finale of
Breaking Bad that's it there's no more
no more Felina it's done last episode
you know and it was highly anticipated
everybody's waiting to see it so what
are your initial thoughts there's such a
great i think it's it ended the way
needed to i think maybe you know later
we'll talk with this you know maybe
where it goes down is how good of a
serious it actually is compared may be
of some of the Great's you know later on
uh but it was great i think it ended the
way needed to I thought every moment was
great it was tense you know I didn't
know was gonna happen I was yeah just a
lot of anticipation I mean I did what a
good finale should do you know mrs. in
Los this isn't like there's no like high
concept thing that needs to be solved
like the mystery it's just a story about
people especially to people which we see
the importance of this episode is Jesse
and Walt yeah I mean Skylar inthere
around doing their thing but the story
is Jesse and Walt yeah I thought it was
really fitting i think it was well done
and and while there weren't really any
big surprises it was it was all there
was like little surprises here and there
but it was definitely nothing that was
like oh my god it's so shocking you know
but it was more like oh that makes sense
right yeah and that you know that fits
into that person's character and what
not and so i thought it was a good
send-off you know so many times you have
series that that end you know either you
know badly or ice controversially i
don't think this is one that's all in it
cause people to be upset why they do
that that was stupid yeah there might be
some people who like oh I wanted more or
mine something else to happen but I
don't think there's anything in this
finale to be like oh my god right you
know sound like Hank like rose from the
grave right I knew the show has an
advantage it's not like it says not a
high-concept show it's not lost its not
bounce our galactic or has to wrap up
this like huge arc I mean it's the it
ended with with Jesse in wall you know
facing off and in a way even though it
wasn't the face off my thought it would
have been but I mean I think it just it
was great I mean maybe should start you
know going to the beginning and look
okay yeah the beginning of the episode
we kind of have see won't trying to get
into that car and I actually didn't
think this scene was exactly necessary
because we had assumed already from the
last episode that when they went to the
bar and he wasn't there right that he
was gone usually knows dispensed because
you know he gets back home eventually so
it's like we know he makes sense yeah
but I did like the gas station scene I
mean not only because he was calling for
the source and find out where he was but
i like it because when the car pulls up
you'll see the license plate for New
Hampshire yeah and the motto is live for
your diet you know is foreshadowing to
what's gonna happen those well yeah
which is you know either he can live
free right yeah or he will die which I
and most likely you know we thought he
was gonna die I thought he was gonna
poison him side where the cancer would
get him at some point ya ya killin right
so what did you think of the scene where
Walt breaks into the Schwartz's house
eliane great that's great i mean it has
the elements to break me that we love it
has the suspense but also of course you
find this out later that dark humor of
course getting to see you know skinny
Pete and the badger badger that was
great but I like that cuz i think we
think this episode when he has that big
gun he think he's gonna go scarface it's
gonna be a scar face was like so hello
to my little friend start wasting
everybody but he didn't kill him yeah i
don't think he was going to kill i mean
maybe they said no maybe I know what he
would have done but I mean he wasn't
planning to go kill them you know I
thought that was a great scene I mean he
needed to get back at him some way he
needed to get that last imma call the
last laugh but like get over them on
something look you kind of owe me this
yeah like I cuz I i clear this company i
created the company that you are making
like a billion dollars all problem yea
yea I'm guessing hundreds and hundreds
of millions yeah yeah he got kind of got
screwed out of that right and didn't get
his proper I guess right just like you
need to do this for me like this should
be your like saying I'm sorry it wasn't
a big surprise though that it wasn't
real sharp I know like him like you kind
of knew when the infrared things came up
and was I didn't know was a skinny Pete
badger no but I knew it wasn't like real
him yeah like it was just some I
actually thought it was a machine that
he was right now kind of like how the
one who did
for his car here I thought he actually
had done that with the infantry soldier
I mean he sold it and knows how to
deliver a line he sold it but ya know
wasn't I think though it was a good
moment I mean it's nice to see those
characters who we saw much earlier now I
I know some people have recently you
know just caught up by binge watching
Netflix and I haven't done that I think
I rewatched the first part of season
five a little while ago but it's been so
long since I've even seen these
characters in an episode it's kind of a
nice to see them back out of bringing
that whole story today that's what i
want to give breaking bad credit for I
think it has one of the tightest
narratives of any show over a
five-season pier that I've seen but just
holds everything everything was for a
reason it wasn't my way so they thought
Walt intrudes on Lydia and Todd's
rendezvous ya need to stop using that
Stevie I mean that Steve Steve he'll
kill ya stevie is rough well that sugar
no oh I thought I was like okay I was
like Lydia needs to get bumped off I
mean I don't care I've mentioned this
many times and like she's a very
annoying character yeah do you know
she's just kind of she's very selfish
and like everything she wants like she
tries in like does but she doesn't want
to like even think about the
consequences or even think about like to
feel guilt about it she's wants it done
you know just kill that person just tell
that person yeah so she's kind of in a
way less feeling than even Walter right
Gus or like anyone anyone else she's
like I no no no I don't even want to
think about don't tell me about it right
yeah so it was kind of nice and in a in
the context of the television show not
in real life to see that she got slipped
the ricin yeah I mean it was climbing I
love I means I'm sky skip ahead here but
I like you know when Walt was talking to
Skyler he said you know almost you know
Michael Corleone a moment Godfather you
know tonight I'm gonna take care of all
the family business yeah and he did he
Scott I was worried about that some was
gonna come after them in the future he's
like ain't nobody coming after you
tonight you mean when Walt sets out to
do something he does it he goes all the
way so yeah and uh son speaking of
Skylar um yeah it was a nice moment you
know obviously worries like still
frantic trying to write you know she's
still angry
you know about the whole situation
because she still hasn't seen Hank
spotting I mean she pre she's probably
like pretty sure he's dead but she's
still holding on to that little bit of
hope and then it she's so scared I love
actually like Skyler maybe one my
favorite moments I've ever seen Skylar
and again I know people up to the
defender because of her Newsweek article
on her Emmy wars but i still think she
wasn't a well-written character gay
nothing against Anna Gunn I think there
was a character very well but I liked
her in this scene because she wasn't
intimidated by him she's like you have
five minutes she's kind of determines
the smoking her cigarettes just numb to
everything like you have five minutes
well even still though she still has
feelings for her cuz he she knows like
really look like crap you know you look
awful like she's just worried not black
and white you know it's a situation yes
he's done all these horrible things he's
you know basic kind of destroyed their
family um but she still cares for him
you can even in that coldness you can
still see she lets him see the baby
right yeah for 45 minutes you know she
knows that he's well not a good person
yeah she's like a cheer go down all
right yeah I mean it's still they made
that baby together that's their child I
mean yeah and you can't you don't just
lose all those feelings even the person
becomes a crazy meth dealer yeah oh yeah
it was so that was a that was a nice
send-off I think it is interesting
though that we never got another moment
with junior yes well junior with win
yeah I never saw because he knows I saw
him but didn't cuz he knows that he
would neatly start yelling and screaming
and kind of ruin all the plans I know
that's why he didn't do it um also he
gave a Skylar that the coordinates to
Hanks body so that she could trade that
to get them free of what every or less
time or whatever you know and and you
know and by the end of the episode we
know that that that Walt is you know
dead lying in the middle of the meth lab
so he's been clear that should help a
little bit yes God had nothing to do was
ruin I wasn't a part of that yeah okay
and now to the big you know finale
scenes which is a waltz meeting up with
when the
you know those Nazis and Todd's whole
crew because they know he knows that
when he's going there that they're
they're gonna kill him I mean who knows
that and he knows that that whole deal
thing about the I'm gonna you know make
a myth without methyl me which he knows
they're not gonna take you know I don't
even think it's even possible i think
raise prices have made that stuff oh so
he'd meet up with them and and you know
take care of business right yeah settle
all scores and it was I mean you know as
much as I want to say like that was it
was a cool scene you know the invention
he did but that's not you know what the
episodes about and she I but I mean it
was cool he's the invention him in the
desert kind of making yeah cool so they
kinda you know when a huge surprise on a
prior cool that but I mean the scene
when I got real was when you kind of
want to see what jesse was gonna do of
course he soon as you see Todd duck and
when the first bull goes you know that
he's gonna at least survive past the
initial bombardment and then after that
of course he and Jesse strangle him that
was cool then she just went to get free
I mean it's just all that stuff going on
and Hank you know dealing with Todd's
uncle and taking him out there's a lot
going on oh sorry Walt are you hey yeah
for Hank we want Hank for Hank he's gone
while dealing with Todd's uncle yeah I
was just a lot going on in that scene
yeah and also you finally get not total
Redemption but Walt does save Jesse yeah
the Jackals of man who tackles him on
purpose to make it he's like oh I'm
gonna pretend he pretends it matter you
gonna fight you yeah but really he's
he's saving his life so he can kill
everyone else and the reason Todd
servise is cuz he's trying to like break
them up right yeah and everyone else get
you know slaughtered so it's kind of a
small redemption from Walt and Jesse got
to you know kill Todd which I don't
think he had any remorse over no Moshe
like was it Gail he killed uh you know
um well cuz he had nothing against gay
right yeah odd he he knows Todd killed
that little kid I'm on the bicycle yeah
and the trainer nice definitely nice he
knows Todd killed the girl yeah he's got
a ex-girlfriend yeah you know and so to
him like he wants to murder he wants
them oh yeah
ha he's been there for months now are
just in his yeah i mean so it was good i
mean i think and eight on the end of
course and they they get out and they
had the little standoff and you know
Jesse can see that he's bleeding out and
you know he's not gonna make it that
easy for him i think that was a good
answer he said if you want if you want
to do this like do it yourself you know
you admitted me that you want to die you
know do it man up and do yourself and
then Jesse sees that Walt's injured so
he knows that either Walt is either
gonna die from the injury the police are
gonna get him right and three there's
probably a small part of him that
realizes that what did spare him because
he easily could have just ducked him
sighs and let Jesse die but i think that
was Walt's way of saying goodbye to
jessie and i assume even though it's
hard to tell with distances but i assume
Jesse overheard the phone conversation
to some what could i think once he hung
up and threw the phone away then they
looked at each other i don't know if he
did here we're talking to Lydia about
the rice and all that and but then they
call it to each other and you know kind
of did the whole yeah like I don't think
this show I mean feta Gilligan's not i
mean i don't think he means that they
made peace I don't think it's test to
comp it's too much drama between them
but they at least had an understanding
yes like look I'm probably not gonna
survive this is probably it you know
Jessie's free yeah and to show too much
has happened I mean these people done
some horrible things you can't have a
nice neat tidy ending yes he might be
free but he's crazy dude screaming and
yelling happy and sad all the same time
and who knows I mean it's I don't know i
really i really enjoyed the ending yeah
yeah it was good and you know obviously
it and walter goes to the meth lab kind
of like I thought you should get one
more cooking I thought that's why they
like finish the batch and then died yeah
that is not put on the light of the suit
that hazmat suit and put on the goggles
everything I thought he's gonna you know
yeah I also thought he's gonna be one
last cook and then have the cops come in
while he's like running up a batch or
something like that goodlife the Skyler
said during the you know when they're
talking Scott when he admitted that he
had done all for him he said yeah they
did it for me because I like they said
he felt he was alive ya doing it's a one
time he felt like he was alive I think
it's a kind of plate replaces that void
he has from losing out on the the grey
matters the big company
and so this was his thing that he built
himself and he was good at and and that
I think is the same thing with jesse's
his little like fantasy dream of himself
in the woodshop yeah like the box it was
basically like well like I could have
you know this which it would have been a
much happier life for me something I
could have been simple something
something he could be proud of like oh I
could do this right instead you know
that's what the show was done I mean
that show is just shows what you know
greed and you know vani just chasing
after that one more thing we won't never
needed all this stuff I mean even if he
was couldn't afford the medical bills I
mean they would have made it somehow he
had a loving family he had kids I loved
I mean he had everything he had a
brother-in-law that support made fun of
him but he still support I mean he had
everything he needed and I mean all
these guys kept chasing and chasing for
that one more thing in the end it just
it destroyed all of them I mean even
Jesse you could say he got away free but
his life I mean yeah once his lives are
never gonna say in their lives their
living this up a little place all right
you know um I got a little bit for the
rest of the life they had to change
their name so that they don't you know
or associate but you know eventually
people gonna find out I have to live
with that you know who knows what kind
of problems the baby girl is gonna have
allergies oh right yeah and learns about
her dad and stuff like that so so that's
what I liked about it I mean they kind
of kept some hopeful moments but you
always knew that like it wasn't quite
right i mean even with the money it's
like just because the kid's gonna get
nine million dollars or whatever is
gonna get from the people doesn't mean
his life's gonna be yeah you know it's
still gonna be messed up so i think they
held on Gilligan has team did a good job
of holding on to the consequences of
living a life like that how it affects
everybody around them yeah yeah and and
how it touches people who you are kind
of a guilt-free like the Walt Jr you
know and the Holly the the baby no baby
girl like those two are guilt free but
they're going to suffer some of the
later ramifications of of what won't did
and two smaller degree what Skyler did I
was gonna ask you just before we finish
and where do you put this I mean I know
it's still early means gotta marinate
but amongst your favorite shows of all
time een as a narrative like how do you
think the story wrapped up over five
seasons I think it's a / pretty up there
I mean probably like top 10 of them I
think I'm not one of those people who
run around go Breaking Bad's the best
show ever made I know a lot of people do
and that's great for me personally I
have other shows above it um there were
certain little wonky stuff that happened
especially in season three years and
three was Leo yeah we're getting a
little too cartoony for me you know but
I definitely love the way that they
wrapped up the series and having a
finale that that that you know was
satisfying and wrapped up a lot of stuff
I'm not a person that needs everything
wrapped up you know alright so cuz I
know some people do when they watch a
finale for certain show it's like if
they don't you know tie up every single
lose and they get upset you know I'm not
one of those people so but I know that
there are some out there and I don't
think Breaking Bad can be faulted for
them no I think it's good i think it has
wanted for me one of the better like I
said early one by their narratives that
everything kind of comes to go and they
use everything in the show some one
phrase I can't take credit for some of
this but the show never really needed a
restart and you know like a loss may be
like during what the midway through
season to season through the needs
electrical okay what are we gonna do for
the next five years the show is going to
run need to figure out something the
gloss never need a pretty but never
needed to do a research is kind of kept
chugging along as best it could they
don't worry there we go right they kept
chugging along so I think as narrative
lee i love it so my favorite show of all
time but i think it's it's definitely up
there for me not family well done yeah
alright guys so that's why you thought
of the breaking bad series finale all
over it's all over i know some lot of us
are sad i mean i'm sad as well but you
know there's always other shows they're
gonna come on and yeah hopefully uh get
get hooked to them as well alright yeah
you can post your comments on the
website or this youtube video below make
sure to subscribe to our youtube channel
which is a think hero pro and you also
can find us on twitter minds at kink era
i'm at griffin de and we also have a
Facebook page that's a facebook.com
slash take care of fans
you